people overthink positioning like I talk  a lot lately about don't be an expert be  an Enthusiast everyone's losing in  content right now because they're like  I'm an expert and then we are like  you're not and it's over before you  start I've never said I was an expert  and I actually am in the [ __ ] that I  talk about I did 15 years of wine before  I talked I did 40 [ __ ] 30 years of  business before I talked and never say  the word expert too many people worry  about the positioning because they think  that's the thing that gets it done it's  not it's the truth that gets things done  people call me everything you think I  think I'm a [ __ ] motivational speaker  I do not think I'm a motivational  speaker do I think many people position  me sure all of it's irrelevant it's all  about what the actual truth is